pourquoi est ce que justement que vous
disiez gilet jaune sur le parcours
estelle vous avez pu discuter avec
quelques-uns d'entre eux sur justement
le dispositif de sécurité qui est mise
en place
[Musique]
oui exactement on a par exemple pu
parler à nda inda qui est
l'organisatrice l'une des déclarants
temps de cette manifestation je propose
d'ailleurs de l'écouter la manifestation
commence est très très bien y'avait pas
de souci on a commencé à nous c'est
resté sur la voie publique sur la
chaussée
j'ai demandé à ce que justement il
écarte un peu leur dispositif que les
gens puissent marcher facilement
aisément pas ya eu des coups deux des
coups de coudes et tout et voilà pour le
mouvement un peu du mal à
à s'accrocher et on trouve important de
montrer que voilà après un an
on est toujours là et qu'on lâche pas on
lâchera pas c'est pas comme ça qu'ils
nous feront lâcher on a beau être gazés
on a beau pleurer dire parfois vomir nos
tripes mais tant pis non mais là ce
coronavirus pendant ce temps là on ne
parle plus de la réforme des retraites
pendant ce temps là on ne parle plus des
agriculteurs qui se suicide
550 victimes sdf qui morts chaque année
pendant ce temps là on ne parle pas de
la dette du pays qui fait que péter mais
le bon motif parce que macro est
incapable de réaliser ses objectifs
financière ce sera à cause du
coronavirus l'an dernier c'était à cause
du gilet jaune
tout est manipulation
voilà pour les revendications samantha
pour ce qui est du partage ici et bien
il semble avoir redémarré un tout
doucement en direction de bercy donc
après après cette petite heure de
tension qui a éclaté entre les forces de
l'ordre et les manifestants je vous le
rappelle le cortège est resté à l'arrêt
pendant une bonne heure à l'intersection
entre le boulevard saint-marcel et le
boulevard arago c'est là que des
tensions sporadiques ont éclaté entre
les manifestants et les forces de
l'ordre les manifestants qui ont parfois
jeté des projectiles en direction des
forces de l'ordre et les forces de
l'ordre qui ont donc répliqué avec des
gaz lacrymogènes voilà pourquoi est ce
que je peux vous dire sur la situation
au moment où je vous parle souvent tard
les 17 interpellations les forces de
l'ordre ont procédé donc à 17
interpellations en fin de matinée on
voit toujours ici donc ce cortège qui
évolue vous l'avez bien précisé estelle
farges en cortège qui poursuit sa route
vers bercy ce le point de chute de cette
journée manifestation 70e actes donc des
gilets jaunes qui même malgré le
contexte de crise sanitaire est bien le
mouvement est descendu se remobilise
donc pour faire entendre sa voix vous
avez entendu donc leurs revendications
ils ne souhaitent pas que la crise
sanitaire du coronavirus et bien relègue
le
leur combat en 2d plan donc ils sont
déterminés donc à faire entendre leur
voix et vous voyez donc sur ces images
en direct toujours les forces de l'ordre
qui encadre bien le cortège
à l'arrière il ya on voit les fourgons
donc de crs et puis à l'avant du cortège
ont envoyés ici donc c'est un cordon de
sécurité chez eu des heures on l'a
précisé en fin de matinée des heures
donc entre la police et les manifestants
avec des gaz lacrymogènes c'est encore
un petit peu tendu à on voit pourquoi
j'ai voulu tant bien que mal vers bercy
c'est pas forcément évident pour les
gilet jaune de manifester puisque on
voit qu'ils sont encadrés que les forces
de l'anp sous pression justement pour
éviter
débordements éventuels voilà ce que l'on
pouvait dire sur cette manifestation
donc des gilet jaune pour ce 70e pacte
et gilet jaune
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà on se retrouve à nouveau avec à la
une les gilet jaune à paris pour le 70e
acte malgré les risques liés aux
coronavirus des tensions avec la police
ce matin on le disait dg de barrières
des gaz lacrymogènes un cortège qui a
démarré depuis la tour montparnasse la
direction bercy en fin de matinée les
forces de l'ordre ont interpellé 17
performant chez nous le dernier bilan du
coronavirus fait état de 18 décès
supplémentaires en 24 heures au total on
n'en coûte 79 pays s'apprête à vivre une
semaine au ralenti
pas d'école travail à distance transport
transport réduits et sorties culturelles
annuler les dernières consignes des
pouvoirs publics pour tenter de freiner
l'épidémie siens et dans le monde on
compte 5544 décès aux états unis
deux mille personnes contaminées 47
morts c'est l'état d'urgence à donald
trump l'annoncé hier il développe 50
milliards de dollars d'aig pour lutter
contre le virus
ailleurs l'italie déplorent 1300 des
faits l'iran à 6 ans
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france on
prend la direction de paris où les gilet
jaune ce nom sont nombreux pour une
nouvelle jean les manies de
manifestation malgré le contexte de
crise sanitaire 1 70e actes et des
heurts avec la police
plusieurs interpellations en marge de la
manifestation 17 au moins 7 en fin de
matinée le cortège qui est qui a repris
qui étaient bloquées donc dans le 3e
arrondissement il est reparti des heurts
avec les forces de l'ordre je vous le
disais
qui vous fêtez l'âge de gaz lacrymogènes
les gilets jaunes qui étaient plusieurs
centaines au départ de la tour
montparnasse direction bercy quelles que
soient les estimations en tout cas la
restriction des rassemblements à 100
personnes fixé par le gouvernement est
largement à dépasser on retrouve en
direct de la manifestation d'entre eux
remportèrent estelle farges
estelle alors vous suivez donc cette
manifestation de près il ya eu des
tensions on a observé des gaz
lacrymogènes jets de barrières
expliquez-nous un peu ce qui s'est passé
depuis cette fin de matinée
oui exactement sa vente alors ce que je
peux vous dire pour le moment vous allez
le voir sur ces images de nicolas
winkler le cortège a repris sa route en
direction de bercy sa destination finale
alors vous l'avez dit des tensions ont
éclaté un petit peu plus tôt est ce qui
s'est passé en fait c'est que le cortège
est resté à l'arrêt à l'intersection
entre le boulevard saint-marcel et le
boulevard arago pendant une petite heure
et c'est là que des tensions ont éclaté
entre les forces de l'ordre et les
manifestants des manifestants qui ont
envoyé quelques projectiles sur les
forces de l'ordre et les forces de
l'ordre qui ont donc répliqué à coups de
gaz lacrymogènes alors vous le voyez
dans le cortège est très encadrée c'est
derrière ce cordon de forces de l'ordre
que donc plusieurs centaines de
manifestants sont rassemblés pour cet
acte soixante dix
voilà une situation toujours un petit
peu tendu on ici et samantha sur ce
boulevard à saint-marcel alors malgré
l'interdiction des rassemblements de
plus de 100 personnes et malgré à
l'épidémie de coronavirus est bien allé
gilet jaune ont tout de même maintenu
leur appel à manifester pour cet acte 70
non merci beaucoup est el farj pour
toutes ces précisions donc vous suivez
ce 70e acte d gilet jaune or on le voit
ici donc dans le xiiie arrondissement ça
reste tendue avec de légers incendies
qui donc que l'on peut observer ici une
moto apparemment qui est incendiée on
voit les pompiers à l'oeuvre pour tenter
d'éteindre ce feu on voit le cortège qui
évoluent il est resté bloqué longtemps
donc comme vous l'avez expliqué dans le
xiiie arrondissement à l'arrière on voit
donc des fourgons donc à l'arrière du
cortège et plus devant si on a pu voir
des
un important dispositif sécuritaire vous
voyez c'est tendu parce qu'il ya de
nombreuses interpellations de nombreux
contrôles aussi 17 interpellations en
fin de matinée ces bilans qu'on peut
donner pour l'instant donc voilà ce que
l'on peut dire sur ces images heures en
direct donc cette mobilisation des
gilets jaunes en pleine crise sanitaire
[Musique]
ou poursuit donc le bilan du coronavirus
en france il s'alourdit 79 morts 800 cas
de contamination de plus que la veille
soit plus de 3600 au total on a appris
que la prise de médicaments
anti-inflammatoires pourrait être un
facteur d'aggravation de l'infection une
information qui émane du ministre de la
santé en écoute justement aux différents
le monde la france font face à une
menace sanitaire inédite que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
qualifie désormais de pandémie et dont
elle estime que l'épicentre est
désormais l'europe
cette menace s'étend dans 118 pays ce
soir elle progresse partout elles
progressent également sur notre
territoire national nous comptons ce
jour 3661 malades soit près de 800 de
plus qu'hier alors à laquelle je vous
parle
soixante dix neuf personnes sont
décédées 154 malades à se trouve
toujours dans un état grave notamment
dans les services de réanimation
ces données nous montrent que l'épidémie
chez vous le disais est installé en
france et plus largement en europe
ces données nous montrent également que
malgré les mesures que nous prenons
l'épidémie progresse c'était attendu la
tour eiffel est fermée jusqu'à nouvel
ordre c'est le cas également d'autres
grands monuments touristiques de la
région parisienne comme le musée du
louvre ou le château de versailles
un coup dur pour la culture et le
tourisme les explications de glee marosi
un seul vaccin vous manque et tout est
dépeuplé alors qu'en italie le
coronavirus a vidé les rues de ces
passants et consommateurs la france se
prépare à une situation similaire les
secteurs de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration font déjà face à une baisse
sévère des réservations et de
l'affluence 22% de manque à gagner dans
la région au de france par exemple
selon une enquête de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie dans le morbihan
ce sont 13 % des entreprises
touristiques du département qui ont dû
fermer temporairement mais avec les
quarantaine et l'interdiction des
rassemblements de plus de 100 personnes
le coc vide 19 va désormais impacter
directement tout un pan de l'économie
des loisirs
à commencer par le monde du septième art
les sorties de plusieurs blockbusters
ont d'ores et déjà été suspendu
à l'instar du remake live de mulan des
studios disney ou des nouveaux mutants
produit par marvel réduisant d'autant la
programmation des cinémas de l'hexagone
des cinémas dont les salles devraient
par ailleurs probablement fermer les
unes après les autres afin d'éviter la
propagation du virus
idem pour les musées qui ont annoncé ce
vendredi fermé leurs portes jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
à paris le louvre le musée d'orsay
l'atelier des lumières ou encore le
château de versailles n'accueilleront
plus leurs dizaines de milliers de
visiteurs quotidiens au cours des
prochaines semaines
même les parcs d'attractions ne sont pas
épargnés à disneyland paris les
visiteurs profitent ici du dernier jour
d'ouverture du parc avec trois employés
testé positif aux coronavirus le site se
passera de visiteurs jusqu'à fin mars
par principe de précaution selon les
calculs du secrétariat d'état au
tourisme
la filière devrait perdre 10 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires sur les
seules quatre premiers mois de l'année
soit plus de 1% du produit intérieur
brut national sur cette période et on
écoute maintenant liem hoang ngoc
économistes selon lui les gouvernements
doivent réfléchir à de nouvelles mesures
concernant les services de santé faut
absolument que les gouvernements
prennent le relais pour financer des
plans de sauvetage
des entreprises en difficulté et aussi
des plans de relance de l'activité
parce que la croissance aujourd'hui tend
vers vers zéro mais les programmes de
relance dont il s'agit ne doivent pas
être des programmes classiques de
relance seulement centrée sur la
redistribution et les mesures de
trésorerie en faveur des entreprises
on a l'occasion pour les gouvernements
ici d'engager une véritable réflexion
sur les nouveaux investissements publics
qui sont nécessaires notamment sur le
plan sanitaire
parce que et les systèmes de santé vont
être mobilisés monsieur macron qui
déclare sa flamme aux services publics
et au modèle social européen devrait un
petit peu retourné kazakh et puis
remettre de l'argent dans les systèmes
de santé et renoncer à détricoter le
modèle social tel qu'il a commencé à le
faire
le bilan mondial du corps la virus
maintenant 5544 mort 143 milles
personnes contaminées dans 136 pays face
à l'épidémie
partout sur la planète on tente de
s'organiser en nouvelle zélande
l'hommage national aux victimes de
l'attentât de christ church a été annulé
en raison des craintes liées au coût de
19 en amérique latine l'uruguay ferme
partiellement ses frontières au brésil
les événements sont suspendues et les
écoles fermées
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
l'annoncé hier l'europe reste tout de
même le nouvel épicentre de la pandémie
l oms a averti qu'il est impossible à
l'heure actuelle de savoir quand aurait
lieu le pic de cette épidémie au niveau
mondial maintenant l'europe est devenue
l'épicentre de la pandémie avec plus de
contamination et de morts que dans le
reste du monde
exception faite de la chine on
enregistre plus de cas chaque jour en
europe qu'en chine au plus fort de
l'épidémie dans le pays qui regarde ce
qui se passe dans d'autres pays touchés
par de grandes épidémies et pensent cela
ne nous arrivera pas commet une erreur
mortelle
cela peut arriver à n'importe quel prix
suite
au bilan toujours plus lourd certains
chefs d'états adoptent des mesures de
plus en plus drastiques nombreux sont
ceux qui décident de fermer leurs
frontières pour éviter toute propagation
c'est le cas de la russie qui a choisi
de fermer sa frontière aux étrangers
avec la pologne et la norvège mesure
également à l'intérieur des pays qui
pour beaucoup décident de fermer leur
école tour d'horizon en images
[Musique]
l'état d'urgence décrété aux états unis
par donald trump après l'annoncé d'un
plan de relance économique le président
américain déclare vouloir débloquer 50
milliards de dollars pour lutter contre
l'épidémie du coronavirus la chambre des
représentants a adopté cette nuit ses
mesures de soutien les précisions de
pierre pissavy yvernault critiqué pour
sa gestion de l'épidémie
donald trump a pris hier une mesure sans
précédent
le président américain a déclaré l'état
d'urgence une mesure traditionnellement
réservé aux catastrophes naturelles
un dispositif qui devrait permettre à
l'état fédéral de débloquer jusqu'à 50
milliards de dollars
le secteur privé vont aussi contribuer à
l'effort national
les laboratoires mobiles et le géant
google travaille déjà pour accélérer le
dépistage en vertu du plan pouvoir du
gouvernement fédéral je déclare
officiellement un état d'urgence
nationale deux très grands mots
la décision que je prends doit permettre
l'accès à 50 milliards de dollars
c'est un montant très élevé est très
important pour les états les territoires
et les localités afin qu'ils puissent
lutter contre cette maladie
chaque état doit mettre en place des
opérations d'urgence
et cette décision prend effet
immédiatement certaines des plus grandes
sociétés des plus grands commerces et
des plus grandes firmes médical du monde
vont s'adresser à vous ces sociétés se
tiennent derrière est à côté de moi
la présidente démocrate de la chambre
des représentants nancy pelosi a annoncé
ce vendredi un accord avec
l'administration trump pour lutter
contre le coronavirus une série de
mesures pour venir en aide aux familles
avec au programme une baisse des
cotisations salariales une aide aux
congés maladie et le renforcement de
l'assurance chômage
une action rapide des démocrates pour
faire passer ce financement d'urgence
était essentielle à la réponse attendue
depuis longtemps de notre pays
le week-end dernier le leader démocrate
du sénat chômeurs et moi avons appelé à
nouvelles mesures pour faire passer les
familles en premier aujourd'hui nous
adoptons un projet de loi qui fait
exactement cela le family first
coronavirus respawns actes qui visent
directement à fournir un soutien aux
familles américaines qui doivent être
notre première priorité aux etats-unis
le problème est donc pris à bras le
corps
selon le président américain 500 mille
tests de dépistages vont être disponible
dès la semaine prochaine
cinq millions d'ici un mois en sait-on
d'affrontements politiques démocrates et
républicains malgré la campagne
présidentielle ont donc décidé de se
battre ensemble pour endiguer l'épidémie
qui a déjà contaminé plus de 2000
personnes et fait au moins 47 morts sur
le territoire américain et dans tout le
pays les américains se ruent dans les
supermarchés pour faire des réserves de
nourriture ce serait la menace d'une
quarantaine ils sont nombreux a dévalisé
les supermarchés pour se procurer les
produits de première nécessité à
nouvelles recherches ville confiné de la
banlieue de new york
la guerre nationale et même déployer
pour aider à gérer un centre de
distribution de nourriture
écoutez on doit juste continuer c'est
génial d'avoir la garde nationale ici
c'est génial que nous soyons des
communautés qui s'unissent et on est là
les uns pour les autres c'est le
meilleur aspect de ça
ils ont annoncé qu'ils allaient fermer
toutes les écoles c'est dur parce que
tous les enfants doivent étudier mais
j'ai certes déjà enjoint donc ils
doivent continuer à étudier mais leurs
enseignants leur ont envoyé les devoirs
qu'ils peuvent faire à la maison
nous avons tous ces nouveaux livres et
nous voulons nous assurer que les
enfants puisqu'ils ne sont pas à l'école
voulant prendre 10 voulons nous assurer
qu'ils continuent à suivre leur
éducation et nous avons c'est libre dans
tous les sites de distribution de new
rochelle où la nourriture est distribuée
et la situation continue de s'aggraver
en italie la péninsule compte plus de
1200 dès ses dix sept mille cas de
contamination encore un navire russe à
la chine d'où est partie l'épidémie a
décidé de soutenir le pays d'europe le
plus touché par le virus neuf experts
chinois et 30 tonnes de matériel médical
sont arrivés à rome
un renfort saluée par les autorités
italiennes nous ne pouvons pas nous
toucher aujourd'hui mais nous pouvons
nous embrasser demain et vaincre ce
virus dès que possible et surmonter
cette urgence aujourd'hui la chine se
relève et bientôt nous nous relèverons
aussi mais seulement avec l'aide de tous
avec cette aide provenant de la croix
rouge chinoise le président de la croix
rouge chinoise le professeur chen zhu a
également envoyé une équipe de
chercheurs qui dans les prochains jours
partageront leur expérience avec nos
chercheurs et médecins en première ligne
dans la lutte contre le court aux
navires us certains d'entre eux viennent
de la province du sichuan près de
l'épicentre
les italiens privés de sortie par le
corona virus pour tromper un éventuel
ennuis causés par les mesures de
confinement nombre d'entre eux ont
répondu à un appel sur les réseaux
sociaux a entonné depuis leurs fenêtres
l'hymne national écoutez
à
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
à et malgré cette note enthousiaste
l'épidémie en italie n'est pas prête de
s'arrêter c'est la conviction d'anna
maria esposito journaliste à la chaîne
de télévision italienne rai news 24
on entend beaucoup de contamination dans
le jour qui est arrivé semaine prochain
d'ici dix jours là bas un jour quand
vous avez dit longtemps l'idée jeudi les
soirs des el2 par la chine
nous avons tous aujourd'hui en meeting
rencontre entre le 9 mai des singes
chinoises qui sont venus de qui sont
arrivés devone et ils ont remporté aussi
beaucoup des d'un certain mika de
ventilateurs pour vos nerfs des
militaires en a tant qui est l'erreur et
les pays de l'europe mais aussi la
france ou est en train d'aller à voter
mais ou non nous sommes en train de
décider de les envoyer notre élection
régionale d'ici qui on entend en
empruntant de l'envoyer à l'automne et
c'est la mesure très rigide qui paie
aider dans ce moment quand je vous dis
on attend la cobac loire le type de
contamination selon les spécialistes en
virologie
il ira 60-70 de sondés
où sont des personnes qui sont
contaminées voilà on vient chez nous à
paris où les gilets jaunes se mobilisent
pour le 70e acte consécutifs 70e samedi
consécutif malgré un contexte sanitaire
on le sait difficile vous voyez ici ces
images en direct du boulevard saint
marcel où le cortège donc
progresse donc pour se diriger vers
bercy si les images d'interpellations en
compte 17 depuis cette fin de matinée
on va rejoindre tout de suite un gilet
jaune david poulin bonjour david poulin
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france
alors votre syndicat voulait constructif
appelé à stopper toutes les
manifestations et les rassemblements
durant la période de confinement on voit
qu'aujourd'hui les gilet jaune battent
le pavé à paris
ils sont plusieurs centaines on le voit
ils sont bien encadrés par un dispositif
sécuritaire très important qu'on pensez
vous alors nous entendons la colère qui
planait en france depuis des années nous
comprenons aujourd'hui qui est beaucoup
de colère de la part des citoyens
français parce que la situation sociale
se dégrade et que le mépris du
gouvernement augmente nous entendons
aussi la colère des syndicats
mais à un moment ou à un autre nous
sommes en train de vivre un moment de
notre histoire unique et très dangereux
pour notre démocratie notre économie et
pour le social dans notre pays qui
s'appelle le coronavirus on parle de 200
à 300 morts par jour en italie
je crois qu'il serait il est judicieux
c'est ce que nous pensons d'arrêter
toute manifestation pendant la période
de confinement qui va durer peut-être un
ou deux mois
quitte à les reprendre après mais pour
par respect par respect des personnes
qui peuvent être mises en danger parce
que nous sommes là pour défendre le
pouvoir d'achat
nous sommes là pour défendre la justice
sociale et fiscale dans notre pays nous
sommes pas là pour propager un virus
supplémentaire parce que si on ne sait
pas ça
nous donnons le beau rôle à nos
adversaires notamment gouvernement qui
pourra justifier après ses actions en
disant que le gilet jaune n'écoute pas
et propagent ce virus là donc c'est
contre-productif donc nous demandons
gilet jaune de rentrer chez eux le plus
vite possible alors dans le même temps
il ya c'est vrai cette ligne de conduite
que vous appelez un hier on a entendu
aussi jérôme rodriguez quelques figures
sur la même
ligne notamment maxime nicole mais dans
le même temps aussi on l'a entendu c'est
vrai que le gouvernement a pris des
mesures drastiques dont l'interdiction
de tout sens personnes de se rassembler
mais en même temps les manifestations
elles sont pas elles ne sont pas
interdites même s'il ya une
recommandation pour reporter ces
manifestations alors il ya une rumeur
qui court que le gouvernement
utiliserait ces mesures là pour tout
simplement éviter toute contestation
sociale en france
mais alors comment explique-t-on que ce
virus là soient internationales la
problématique gillot ne touche pas tous
les pays du monde donc on voit bien qu'à
une problématique sanitaire grave il
faut l'entendre manifestation pas
manifestations il ya des vies qui sont
en jeu des vies de nos aînés de
personnes fragiles qui aujourd'hui
dépendent du de la bonne citoyenneté du
bon comportement de chacun et de la
solidarité c'est maintenant qu'il faut
démontrer que nous sommes un peuple fort
et un peuple solidaire
donc on nous appelons à ne pas
manifester et au contraire à reprendre
les manifestations si nécessaire après
la période de confinement qui s'arrêtera
d'ici un ou deux mois
vous craignez pas vous ne craignez pas
finalement que votre mouvement
s'il ne poursuit pas ces manifestations
consécutives
et bien finalement il ne puisse pas se
relancer à un moment donné ça fait deux
ans parce qu'enfin un peu plus d'un an
et demi que nous manifestons
régulièrement les messages sont passés
le moment j ai jaune est en train
d'influencer tout l'échiquier politique
mais aujourd'hui ce que j'observe c'est
qu'il ya des gilet jaune mais il ya
beaucoup aussi de groupuscules d'extrême
gauche voire d'ultra gauche qui veulent
en découdre
donc il faut pas tomber dans ce piège là
il faut continuer le combat de défense
de justice sociale et fiscale dans notre
pays mais aussi on est dans un moment de
l'histoire où une crise sanitaire
importante est en train de naître qui va
peut-être et je dis bien peut-être
déboucher sur une crise économique
majeure
avec toutes les personnes qui vont
perdre leur emploi qui n'ont pu avoir
des preuves de pouvoir est certainement
sur une crise politique exceptionnel
donc ça d'étendre la durée de ce
confinement sa dépendent de l'impact je
ne sais pas ce qui va se passer mais
notre rôle en tant que syndicat en tant
qu'association en tant que citoyen tout
simplement c'est essayer d'être
solidaire à l'égard des autres et
d'éviter de faciliter la pro à la
contagion de ce virus
on parle quand même de 300 morts par
jour en italie ça veut dire que ce sont
des chiffres qui maintenant est un
événement totalité sur moins important
que la grippe saisonnière mais si on
compare au jour en italie on est
beaucoup plus que la grippe saisonnière
en france qui tue environ 250 à 300
personnes par semaine
donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut foncer tête
avoir cent mille morts en france pour
réagir donc je ne veux pas participer à
la contagion de ce virus à qui peut tuer
des gens dans ma famille des proches et
je pense qu'il fait judicieux de pouvoir
déposer le pavé pendant quelques mois le
temps que la contagieuse soit terminé et
repartir après dans les manifestations
si nécessaire maintenant je crois que le
combat doit être ailleurs il doit être à
la fois dans le mouvement syndical dans
le mouvement social associatif et
surtout en politique c'est ce que je
pense c'est notre point de vue je ne
sais pas si vous avez eu des échos de la
manifestation qui se déroule
actuellement à paris bon il ya un
important dispositif de sécurité c'est
une manifestation qui est déclarée entre
harnes à bercy il ya d'autres quartiers
de la capitale qui sont interdits aux
manifestations même s'il ya eu un appel
je crois à reprendre les champs elysées
enfin bon là pour l'instant ça se
déroule vraiment sur ce parcours
montparnasse bercy le boulevard
saint-marcel et ce dispositif
sécuritaire qui est très important on
sait difficile même pour les gilet jaune
de d'évoluer même au sein de ce cortège
vous en tout cas le regard on portait
justement sur ce dispositif aujourd'hui
c'est toujours le même l'objectif c'est
tout simplement de réprimer toute
contestation sociale on le voit bien
avec les femmes on l'a vu avec l'école
et des manifestations pour
l'environnement on le voit aussi au
niveau des syndicats on voit bien qu'on
est dans une confrontation d'une france
éclaté qui était au bord de tomber dans
le précipice des extrêmes on le sait ça
aujourd'hui mais nous sommes dans un
contexte de virus internationale dans
quelque chose qui nous dépasse et il
faut être montrer qu'on est un grand
peuple solidaire et nous entendu les jo
nous sommes solidaires par rapport aux
personnes qui risquent d'attraper ce
virus là parce que c'est très dangereux
parce qu en allant manifester on peut
transmettre le virus à d'autres
personnes qui sont fragiles ils nous ne
voulons pas porter cette responsabilité
là nous sommes dans un combat social et
fiscal et nous allons remporter ce qu'on
va nous le savons il faut avoir
confiance et on va leur prendre d'autant
plus une fois que le virus aura disparu
de notre vie quotidienne
aujourd'hui la priorité c'est la
solidarité merci beaucoup david poulin
président l'union syndicale des gilets
jaunes que l'on appelle donc les
constructif merci à vous rejoins ce
chiffre en direct de la manifestation
notre reporter à estelle fâchent
mais estelle alors vous êtes toujours
sur place du côté donc du boulevard
saint-marcel beaucoup beaucoup de de
sécurité 1 pour encadrer justement cette
manifestation 70e acte d gilet jaune
oui exactement
samantha on se trouve boulevard
s'inversait les vous allez pouvoir le
voir derrière moi sur ces images de
nicolas winkler ils sont plusieurs
centaines de gilet jaune à s'être
rassemblés derrière ce cordon de forces
de l'ordre alors pour le moment le
calmer et est revenu un ici un calme
tout à fait précaire mais le cortège est
bien est encore est encore à l'arrêt sur
ce boulevard saint-marcel un petit peu
plus tôt en détention ont éclaté entre
les forces de l'ordre et les
manifestants en cortège toujours à
l'arrêt donc à un cortège qui devait
rejoindre bercy en destination finale de
cette manifestation animaux enfin pour
vous dire que selon la préfecture de
police à 15 heures les forces de l'ordre
ont procédé à plus de 900 contrôle des
contrôles qui ont abouti à 25
interpellations
merci beaucoup c'est el farj pour toutes
ces précisions va vous retrouver tout à
l'heure donc vous suivez donc ce 70e as
tu des gilets jaunes voilà oms on va se
terminer ce journal donc sur ces images
en direct on va se retrouver dans 30
minutes pour faire un nouveau point
rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
hajj imad personnellement j'ai grandi au
milieu de la guerre les sanctions
internationales et de l'injustice
on voit vraiment un singe
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à travailler avec les
enfants abandonnés en 2003 après
l'invasion de l'irak par les américains
ma mère m'a emmené dans une autre ville
où j'ai vécu avec ma tante
ma mère est restée un fallout york c'est
là qu'ils sont morts nous sommes donc
nombreux ils sont maintenant orphelins
comme nos maisons que l'on rejoint
daraîche et je n'avais pas envie de
rester avec eux si je l'avais fait je
serais devenu l'un d'entre eux
[Musique]
etac j'avais peur mais monsieur hicham a
commencé à changer ma vie j'aurais
peut-être a rejoint un groupe terroriste
ont un gang s'il n'avait pas été là ne
peut pas espérer que les enfants qui ont
grandi sans droit pour respecter ceux
des autres
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france
au sommaire aujourd'hui la guinée-bissau
deux mois après le scrutin présidentiel
ce pays s'enfonce dans une nouvelle
crise politique suscitée par un
contentieux électoral et cela malgré les
efforts de médiation de la communauté
internationale ce petit pays de l'ouest
de l'afrique dont la capitale se
prénomme également bissao et parfois
confondu à tort avec sa voisine